we received a very very angry voicemail
at two one nine to david p over the
weekend and i don't think it needs much
of an introduction i'll just play it for
you you on american why don't you when
your little sidekick go back to
argentine or wherever the hell you
belong if this country gave you the
right to be on on the TV I just turned
it out I turned it off
you people are jerks get rid of Pledge
of Allegiance why don't you get rid of
you and you know what your mother likes
to suck clay you know acquiesce you on
American you know we should run you out
you you you alien and that a little
flake little fairy boy that sits there
with you you two wouldn't play with each
other
incisive critique the what why would Pat
go back to our like you've never even
been to Argentina never mind you're not
you're obviously not from Argentina
you've never even been how would you
what legal basis would there be for
sending you to Argentina I'd love to go
to Argentina max let me actually take
this caller under advisement this is
this is what we're dealing with this is
what we're up against okay and we're not
sugarcoating it I'm not presenting it as
more than it is but I am letting you
that's the full unedited scope of it
there were two more that came
immediately after that by the way which
contained language which was not okay
for FCC broadcasting but maybe what
we're thinking of a new rejected
voicemail segment on instagram and david
pakman show so maybe we would we would
use it there this is what we're up
against and this is why i'm telling you
that it is much more effective to go out
and get people to vote we have fifty
percent voter turnout you can convince
five people i would argue you can
convince fifty people to vote before you
are gonna change the minds of someone
like this guy and that's why that's
where the focus needs to be for 2018
for 2020 and so on and so forth we have
a fantastic bonus show today
Omarosa tells NPR that she has heard the
trump and word tapes we're going to talk
about that we're going to talk about her
leaking or publishing the tape that she
made of john kelly firing her from the
White House it is compelling I listen to
it just a little while ago we will talk
about the Trump administration planning
to overhaul a program
that's designed to save Medicare money
why would they want to do that why
wouldn't they want to save Medicare
money I think we can probably guess why
and lastly congressman keith Ellison is
denying domestic abuse accusations we
will also talk about that on today's
bonus show get the bonus show support
the david pakman show become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show or
sign up for membership at WWN pakman.com